pierre martinet bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors viennent
toucher c'est un peu l'objectif du
terrorisme semer la terreur et frapper
n'importe où et n'importe quand alors
oui mais pas n'importe quel terrorisme
c'est le terrorisme islamiste je fais
une remarque j'ai une remarque
première remarque concernant toutes les
commandes il a gelé les mots de soutien
des différentes par différents
représentants des gouvernements
européens
à aucun moment par le terrorisme
islamiste il serait enfin temps de tous
s'unir pour avoir le même langage pour
lutter contre cet ennemi c'est à dire le
nommer précisément de terrorisme c'est
un moyen
le terrorisme est ce un moyen d'imposer
une idéologie il ya plusieurs terrorisme
là en l'occurrence l'occident et a taclé
par le terrorisme islamiste
l'occident et en particulier l'europe
sont attaqués par le terrorisme
islamiste
donc à partir de là il faut poser de
vraies bases pour lutter contre ce
terrorisme et la voilà la base qui est
en moi très importante c'est d'abord de
s'attaquer à l'idéologie qui alimentent
ces attaques terroristes islamistes
c'est très important l'idéologie
islamiste est propagée par les frères
musulmans et le salafisme et à aucun
moment on ne prend des mesures et à
aucun moment on ne fait état de ces deux
idéologies qui ce qui se dira juste
qu'ils s'unissent pour alimenter le
terrorisme islamiste
effectivement il ya des groupes
islamistes armés comme al qaïda l'état
islamique
il ya les shebab en somalie il ya
multitude de groupes islamistes qui sont
prêts à frapper et localement
régionalement ou internationalement mais
la base la base de cette secte de ces
deux de ces attaques
la source de ces attaques c'est
l'idéologie islamiste
alors quand on fait ce constat un
terroriste islamiste quand vous le dites
qui frappe n'importe quand et n'importe
où c'est difficile alors de le première
j'imagine alors effectivement c'est très
difficile de le prévenir parce que le
principe du terrorisme c'est de frapper
quand on s'attend pas la preuve c'est
qu'ils sont allés frapper
ils ont tapé sur sur l'autriche un pays
où le niveau alerte terroriste était
peut-être moins élevés qu'en france
le terrorisme c'est un peu les montagnes
russes 1 on fera on laisse retomber un
peu la pression
on refera que c'est à dire on autre
qu'un de psychose ambiante régulière et
le cas échéant on peut on peut
déclencher des heurts
intercommunautaires
non c'est difficile on pour répondre à
votre question précisément c'est très
difficile de le prévenir avant sur des
actions comme celle ci qui demande de la
préparation qui demandent de la
logistique qui demande un minimum de
communication sur certains réseaux on
peut on peut on peut le leu leu leu
l'éviter
quand je dis bien on peut mais le risque
zéro n'existe pas en revanche les
attentats qu'ils sont qui sont perpétrés
par des individus qui décident peut même
de frapper quand ils en ont décidé de
frapper et qu'ils sont qui sont en
dehors des radars des unités
antiterroristes c'est impossible a
déjoué en revanche encore une fois je
vais répéter je vais me répéter pour la
100e fois je pense
il est indispensable d'avoir des primes
aux intervenants des six mille et un
petit peu de un maillage de primes aux
intervenants dans les pays concernés je
vais parler de la france de façon à
intervenir
instantanément pour limiter le nombre de
nombre de comment dirais-je de victimes
ça veut dire quoi mais allez vous
demander justement un quel genre de
primes aux intervenants et ou dans le
thé d'être déployée justement alors il y
a j'allais répondre à votre question en
amont enfin avant il est facile et
facilement aujourd'hui il est
indispensable d plus qu urgent d'avoir
un vrai que vous dirigez une vraie
relation
un vrai partenariat entre le public et
le privé
il y à de nombreuses sociétés de
sécurité privées qui sont capables
d'avoir des gens armés
elles sont composées d'anciens
militaires d'anciens policiers d'anciens
gendarmes qui connaissent le maniement
d'armes qui savent utiliser armements il
faut les dissimuler sur le territoire ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les les
points sensibles sont protégés par des
sécurités privées les restaurants les
cinémas les lieux de culte on peut
mettre un ou deux agents armés qui sont
capables d'intervenir instantanément
c'est ce que fait israël israël à des
attentats arrive à déjouer des attentats
malheureusement il ya des gens dont tu
as qui passent au travers de
des mailles du filet en revanche ils ont
des primes aux intervenants qui sont
dissimulés sur la sur le territoire les
sociétés de sécurité privées sont armés
et sont capables d'intervenir
immédiatement c'est à dire dans la
seconde prenez le cas d'un incendie les
110 si vous le laissez si vous le
stopper dans la seconde il y aura peu de
dégâts si vous stoppez au bout de trois
quatre minutes 5 10 minutes
les dégâts sont considérables c'est
exactement la même chose alors il est
plus que temps d'arrêter de les
concertations et arrêter les rapports et
arrêter les enquêtes les lois de
programmation etc
il est indispensable d'avoir une vraie
relation entre le public et le privé
et à voir les forces de l'ordre qui sont
utilisés pour ce qu'elles doivent pour
ce qu'elle doit faire c'est à dire de
l'enquète de la prévention et tout ce
qui est gardiennage entre guillemets
garder l'âge opérationnel ffo faut
l'attribuer à des structures privées et
là je ne parle pas pour la mienne parce
que moi je suis pas français je suis
anglais alors et à ce qu avec ces
attentats qui se multiplient en
seulement quelques semaines je rappelle
ainsi m elle pâtit qui a été décapitée
assassiné au sens même de la basilique
d'aunis tireur en plein coeur de vienne
hier soir est-ce qu'on n'entre pas dans
une nouvelle ère j'espère que votre
question ne prend pas en compte depuis
2012 tout ce qui s'est passé en europe
depuis 2012 on va dire je pourrais en
beauté en 1995 parce que c'est vraiment
de
ne ces attentats qui ont eu en quelques
semaines voire quelques jours n'est
qu'un tel cas oui d'accord je comprends
votre question mais c'est le principe du
terrorisme c'est à dire aux frappes en
2010 car je vous rappelle qu'il ya dans
la même année il ya eu près de 200 voire
en france 2 sans argent je sais pas
enfin pas loin de 100 à 150 je crois il
ya eu plusieurs attentats en france en
2015 mais c'est le principe du
terrorisme le principe du terrorisme
c'est c'est pas de frapper en continu
c'est de frapper laisser redescendre la
pression et les refrapper après
aujourd'hui on est dans une vague
d'attentats intense vous avez raison ça
veut dire que les terroristes ont avec
tous les messages de haine et de
propagande qu'il ya aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans un an dans une partie du
monde musulman
les terroristes sont capables de
préparer des attentats et se rappeler
pour moi ça suit ça suit le projet
global va commencer en 1928 avec avec un
triptyque qui est bien connu avec un
triptyque qui qui va amener les cetc
islamistes à aboutir leur projet c'est à
dire que il ya une très grosse île aux
idéologies de plus en plus très forte
idéologie en europe qu'on avait pas il
ya 25 ou 30 ou 40 ans s'est accentuée or
aujourd'hui avec vraiment une
imprégnation du salafisme en europe
et comme on dirait une les frères
musulmans qui sont très actifs à tous
les strates de la société
donc là il faut vraiment faire un
travail particulier sur cette idéologie
la deuxième partie c'est le financement
le financement on travaille toutes les
structures comme traque fin et les
autres travaillent sur tous les flux de
financement qui alimentent les réseaux
qui alimente les poches idéologique
partout en europe et partout en occident
le troisième c'est les actions les
actions violentes la france lutte contre
le terrorisme islamistes au sahel et
ailleurs les actions violentes sont
perpétrés en europe et nous avons
heureusement des groupes d'intervention
en europe qui sont capables d'intervenir
assez rapidement maintenant puisqu'ils
ont été disséminés sur le territoire
français un peu partout en europe mais
les quelques minutes qui séparent
l'intervention de groupes comme comme le
jijel le raid l'aderee où des policiers
municipaux ou des policiers nationaux
qui sont dans les rues ces quelques
minutes là on pourrait les combler avec
avec d'une structure privée pour essayer
de limiter les victimes
mais tout ça ce sont les conséquences de
l'idéologie qui ce qui s'est répandue
depuis ces quinze dernières quinze
dernières années mais qui s'est
accélérée depuis cinq dix ans donc ça
c'est important de faire leur travail là
dessus
comment on peut stopper une idéologie on
va parler de la france comment on peut
stopper l'idéologie en france en france
peut être le fer de lance de la lutte
contre l'islamisme en europe est là elle
a très rapidement valjean oui elle a
national juridique qui s'appelle la
laïcité
il est impératif aujourd'hui de remettre
le religieux dans la sphère du privé en
france et de refuser toute revendication
religieuse du quotidien chaque religion
doit être spirituel et personnelles dans
la sphère du privé
monsieur martin et merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle vous n'êtes
pas un ancien agent du service action de
la déesse merci m